BROADCASTER VINCE SCULLY OF THE
PADRES.
>> HE PASSED AWAY AND CNN SPOKE
TO COLLEAGUES AND FANS ABOUT HIS
LEGACY.
>> Reporter: ON A BEAUTIFUL,
BREEZY NIGHT IN LOS ANGELES, THE
THE ADORATION FOR VINCE SCULLY
FLOWED FOR HIM.
PHOTOS WERE TAKEN AND OTHERS
WORE SHIRTS, INCLUDING A YOUNG
MAN WITH VINCE SCULLY ON HIS
BACK.
>> WE HAVE BEEN GRATEFUL TO ALL.
>> Reporter: IN THE PREGAME
CEREMONY SO MUCH EMOTION.
>> VINCE WAS MOST COMFORTABLE IN
THE BOOTH.
>> Reporter: THEY PLAYED AN
11-MINUTE VIDEO TRIBUTE TO HIM.
IT WAS NARRATED BY ONE OF THE
DODGER'S ANNOUNCERS, CHARLIE
STEINER.
>> VIN CALLED 25 WORLD SERIES,
12 ALL-STAR GAMES.
>> HE MAY HAVE BEEN THE BEST
SPORTS ANNOUNCER WHO EVER LIVED.
HE WAS A FRIEND.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS I'M
HAVING DIFFICULTY COMING TO
TERMS IN THE LAST FEW DAYS.
I KNEW HE WAS GOING TO PASS
AWAY, IT CAME AS NO SURPRISE,
BUT, STILL, YOU GET THE CALL AND
IT IS A GUT PUNCH.
SO THIS IS -- TONIGHT FOR ME,
I'M CALLING A GAME, BUT IT IS
ALSO A SENTIMENTAL JOURNEY.
>> VINCE SCULLY, FORDHAM CLASS
OF 1949.
>> IT WAS LIKE YOU GET GOOSE
BUMPS BECAUSE YOU GET TO SEE AND
HEAR HIM AGAIN.
>> A HIGH-FLY BALL TO DEEP LEFT
FIELD.
WOULD YOU BELIEVE A HOME RUN?
AND THE DODGERS HAVE CLENCHED
THE DIVISION AND WILL CELEBRATE
ON SCHEDULE.
>> EVERY TIME YOU HEAR THOSE
FIVE WORDS, "IT'S TIME FOR
DODGER BASEBALL," IT'S JUST YOU
GET CHILLS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THAT'S VINCE.
>> HE WAS A GREAT MAN AND WHAT A
CAREER.
WHAT A CAREER, AND SO HUMBLE.
>> I MEAN I FELL ASLEEP TO HIM.
HIS VOICE WAS SO SOOTHING TO ME
THAT I JUST -- I'M GOING TO MISS
HIM.
>> MY GRANDMA WAS A DODGER, BLED
BLUE.
COULDN'T GO ANYWHERE UNLESS WE
LISTENED TO THE DODGER GAME
ONLINE SO HE HAS BEEN A PART OF
MY LIFE.
>> ICONIC.
ANYWHERE YOU WOULD BE, YOU WOULD
HEAR VINCE SCULLY.
>> IT'S TIME FOR DODGER
BASEBALL!
♪♪
>> I WAS IN TEARS ACTUALLY.
IT IS A CULMINATION OF AN ENTIRE
LIFE THAT WAS DEDICATED TO
BASEBALL AND TO THE CITY OF L.A.
♪♪
>> Reporter: FOR THESE DODGER
FANS, IF HE RAN FOR MAYOR OF LOS
ANGELES, VINCE SCULLY WOULD HAVE
WON.
TO THEM IN A WAY, VINCE SCULLY
WAS TO SPORTSCASTING WHAT LOUIE
ARMSTRONG WAS TO JAZZ.
HE WAS SIMPLY THE BEST.
THEY DON'T WANT TO FORGET